when Stefani receives the Hero Award at
the Radio Disney Music Awards on
Saturday he caught up with a pop star on
the red carpet where she gushed about
the achievement this feels kind of
surreal to be having a moment like this
and just the fact that Radio Disney has
supported my new record - it's just so
crazy Stefani opened up about Powell for
Elle Williams presenting her with the
night's highest honor it's so it's so
crazy because he's been not only um not
just a friend and not just a writing
partner but he's given me so much
confidence and he's been like an angel
he's worked with you he's worked with
beyoncé just put out lemonade both of
you guys have such personal records how
important is that to share your story
with your fans like that I feel like
that's all I've ever been able to do I
always fantasized about being a creative
writer I've received so much love and so
much healing you know from being able to
do that and I feel like I love music
Shivani also talked her long the way to
tour featuring rapper Eve I've never
been on a bus like on tour and years so
I never I never dreamed I would have any
music this record to me is like it's
like my it was like just it came out of
the sky
I mean honestly right out of my heart up
and then out it's like the great mystic
and et learned the singers thoughts on
having boyfriend Blake Shelton and some
kids to possibly join her on the road
there's a lot of work to do before I
could even think about like the actual
going out like there's it's such it's so
much work and it's so incredible and
exciting